what's uh actually can you look at the
most successful franchises where's hello
kitty and poke i know pokemon's one i
think but i don't know is pokemon one
the most successful franchise i think so
in the world yeah above like disney
stuff well yeah because there's no
single property that disney has that is
bigger than
like disney as a whole yeah because then
you'd argue instead of pokemon it'd be
nintendo right yeah yeah yeah right
google most successful franchises number
one is mcdonald's
entertainment
pokemon yeah where's hello kitty on that
list
i think it's in like the top five
no i think it's top ten i think it's
like six or seven yeah um second is
hello kitty yes yeah number two hello
would you like
would you seriously be like yeah dude no
doubt pokemon on one hello kitty second
like when you hear hello kitty second
that doesn't sound right yeah it doesn't
sound right you you're you're writing
that but to me pokemon also doesn't
sound right or maybe maybe no pokemon
does why would you what would you say
has had a bigger effect on like the
world like mario maybe yeah like mario
um i would say pokemon is way bigger
than mario yeah well i mean it is i i
feel like maybe because pokemon you're
right does have its fingers in so many
pies
in terms like in terms like making money
like merchandising and collaborations
yeah pokemon is king and i can see why
it's number one in terms of like how
famous it is or like the widespread
appeal like i would still say there are
bigger icons
i think pikachu is a bigger icon than
mario you think so i think so you think
so i think pikachu is more recognizable
than mario
oh it's hard to say
do you think pikachu is more
recognizable than mickey mouse
no yeah i think i think mickey mouse is
i think i would even argue almost that
maybe hello kitty is more well known as
a character yeah i guess but yeah that
doesn't matter because that's not like
how you know that's yeah yeah that's
exciting but i would argue that that
might be the whole reason why hello
kitty's so successful i mean possibly by
success i assume we mean financial
success
like fight to me financial success
doesn't always equate to what is the
most recognizable icon of all right
right but i know yeah it's my franchise
you know but i wouldn't in terms of like
power and the ability to push something
like yeah like hello kitty is like
nothing compared to pokemon in my mind
yeah but in terms of brand recognition i
feel like hello kitty i think it's just
so much i don't know which is why which
is why like when i think when i think of
successful franchises successful icons
yeah i think of stuff like mickey mouse
mario stuff like that and like to me the
whole pokemon
uh sensation is just it was like it kind
of like blindsided me because i knew
pokemon was big
i didn't know it was that in 1996 it was
the single most googled
know how crazy that is that is insane
porn exists gone
legitimate a universal love of people
online like how
how does it beat that pokemon porn
where's minecraft on that list
oh yeah minecraft's like massive now as
well minecraft in recent years has
become a map yeah yeah yeah
it's so weird because it's franchise
franchises like pokemon like minecraft
where you have this initial explosion
and then everyone thinks it's just gonna
die down and they did it and it does die
down and then it comes back with like a
[ __ ] vengeance yeah it's it's like
the [ __ ] sequel man it's like it's
like goku every time it dies it just
gets stronger
he just died already he's like no
more power [ __ ] saiyans man like
every time they die
okay go go go going on a complete
tangent i never realized how opie of an
ability that is imagine like coming
close to death and then coming and then
powering up by just simply getting the
[ __ ] kicked out of you
so that's sorry that's i'm just i'm just
going on a complete tangent that's like
completely broken ability and no one
ever no one's ever called that okay then
who would you say if we're talking about
brand recognition who would you say is
the most recognizable like anime
character or anime franchise not
including pokemon can you tell me what
you're gonna like 80 seconds it's still
pretty impressive there for a game for a
game yeah behind fast and furious
oh
okay the most recognizable anime figure
yeah like if if the moment someone says
the word anime who is what is the first
thing you think of i have different
answers depending on maybe where in the
world i'm in yeah durham on yeah
doraemon
basically asia in the entire world
i wanna say
it's pikachu but if you don't include
pokemon because pokemon's originally a
game right
is it dragon ball z i don't know would
you think goku
goku probably might be goku because the
question is dragon ball fans who can be
goku
in this situation
who can
go to a brand recognition who can beat
goku can everyone beat goku
we're literally asking a question but
can they be goku can they be goku luffy
no no no i would say naruto
no i yugi
yuki
everyone knows that hair maybe people
maybe know yugi they don't know what the
[ __ ] he is though i would argue maybe
uh naruto is like i would say naruto i'm
maybe not goku naruto doesn't have the
uh naruto doesn't have the legacy right
it's probably goku if it's if we're not
counting pokemon yeah
we're not doing jp only yeah do you know
what surprises me
how popular bleach was and still is
right because like it's only it's only
recently that i've realized how [ __ ]
popular it is oh yeah so i don't know
anything about bleach what i know is
that every time someone is an edge lord
on twitter they like bleach is that is
that a coincidence or is that like no
definitely not no i'm just wondering
because every time they are they have a
bleach profile picture
that that makes sense have you seen the
character designs yeah they're just like
it's like edge yeah yeah but i was like
i just kind of single handed me not want
to watch the show
no no no no i i would i would argue that
like as as someone who was a massive
bleach fan like it's yeah don't don't
let that blind you because it's a great
show after all
yeah okay fine no i mean i knew i knew
there was a huge following for bleach
but i didn't like
i didn't recognize how big the following
was i mean for the longest time it was
like it was bigger than one piece
worldwide i think and it's not just like
not just like a bit bigger than one
piece um it was like
it's it was like massively bigger than
one piece and i guess yeah that kind of
makes sense because one piece didn't
have the greatest launch worldwide well
during yeah i think like during uh the
the first arc the the soul society arc i
think like every week in shonen jump
bleach was just number one yeah actually
the longest time uh can can you search
up the most successful anime franchises
because i think bleach is like up there
on the list it is i think i think i
think that's what surprised me yeah did
you see that sorry i'm totally did you
see the the one piece slash mario figure
collab what where like mario was like
drawn in like one piece style no figure
and he looks like a pirate dude type in
uh one piece mario why haven't i don't
know
it's like a 200 figure and it looks
insane it looked right up your alley
joey one wait what is it one piece one
piece mario figure google it mario
figure
oh my god i want that okay let me see
let me see let me see you'd buy that
immediately it's mario as goldie roger
oh my god that's like that's so cool
i don't know
it comes with the flag as well one peach
one love
it comes with the flag as well oh my
gosh that's so cool
i don't know who made that who made that
i don't know buy it is it i'm gonna buy
it though we're gonna sell out yeah did
it come out recently i think so i don't
know i think it got announced but the
yeah i love this [ __ ] kotaku title
600 super mario bros x one piece
crossover has wonderful hair
bro his hair is on point his hair is on
point to be fair that's actually the
coolest thing i've ever seen
that's a collab that works yeah that's
that's just like
bleach is the
what's number one
just read out the list for us saturday
go on i've got 20 slightly at bottom
okay
is
demon slayer demon slayer number 20.
i'm tara number 12 number 19 okay
that's number 16 right 15. it's pretty
hard
yep
yeah that makes sense
that makes sense
yeah sailor moon makes sense
that's that's shocking what's that oh
yeah so
oh my god how do i explain culture
coming
is uh
for one the longest running manga series
ever okay it has 200 volumes
um went on for about 50 years on shonen
jump and it is
explaining the concept of kochikam is
going to make it sound so boring
it follows the life of a police officer
in the uh kamiyari district of tokyo
that's it wow and like a franchise that
went on for 50 years and the author is
famous for never taking a break okay
okay 50 years 200 200 volumes
yeah yu-gi-oh seven that makes sense
yeah then one piece
one piece at number six what's left
keep going
yeah
oh yeah number five that makes sense
fourth is gundam
i feel like the fifth north star won
that's an anomaly i i feel like i feel
like that's cheating because how much of
that is just uh
how much of that is
not gacha what's what's the other chinko
pachinko how much how much of that
revenue
a lot of them a lot of the anime
franchises ava's done it re-zero's
and like yeah you got your old people
who grew up on fifth and north star what
are they going to spend the money on
pachinko yeah my uncle got into fists
the north star and ava because of the
tree
exactly right exactly it was uh did you
ever see that mario party thing there's
very few arcades have it mm-hmm it's
like a gambling mario party game in the
casino have you seen alex you know in
the arcade sometimes have you seen that
no so you pay money to move on the board
pay money to move on the board yeah you
pay money to move around this board
right that's really weird and there's
one
there was one in the arcade next to the
touhou cinema and shinjuku okay but the
arcade's gone now oh [ __ ] but there used
to be one there yeah and it was oh is
that the one that is that the building
that the vr park was in
no no no that's
maybe maybe it is that yeah yeah because
that building's not there anymore yeah
so they used to have like this mario
party game where you'd have to put money
into like get like gamble a little bit
oh weird and then you would move forward
and you could win uh i think you could
win money okay i'll shoot it's really
weird yeah it's really weird it's very
jarring seeing mario
no no illegal i think it was nintendo
license okay okay
okay yeah i think yeah sometimes
everyone wants nintendo to be like the
the company it's like super good
no because like yeah with uh fist and
lost pachinko that that makes a lot of
sense because it's pachinko makes a [ __ ]
ton of money in japan yeah and that's
why that's why [ __ ] konami sold out
to become a pachinko because the chinko
and mobile games
and all like all the coolest looking
buildings in japan are just pachinko
parlors if a building looks clean and it
looks amazing and it looks fascinating
yeah pachinko there's a there's a
pachinko parlor in yokohama that's
literally shaped like an ava jesus yeah
and it's like and i'm like that is a
cool building what is that oh yeah
yeah whenever i see a building with
bright lights cool anime characters
slapped on everywhere i'm like damn this
is a cool looking anime store [ __ ]
pachinko every time and then the door
opens it's just
it's so depressing all your [ __ ]
years it's easily like the most
depressing [ __ ] thing about japan
yeah everyone's addicted to shooting
these [ __ ] balls into your machine
you could be like in the middle of the
countryside but there will be one cool
building it's insane it'll be the
pachinko it'll be the biggest building
it'll be the biggest building it'll be
like these like rundown houses like the
economy is like depleted and then
there'll be this [ __ ] like egyptian
tomb level of like like intensity it's
massive well lit up like there's rice
fields all around it it's [ __ ]
pachinko it's like five floors it's
insane it's actually insane
like they could have filled they could
have put this thought into so many other
different buildings somebody like maybe
make like a [ __ ] escape room or
something or you know maybe just a cool
store i don't know
arcade no pachinko every [ __ ] time
yeah because that's the [ __ ] that makes
money you know makes money that's sad i
don't get it i don't get it i mean we
did the pachinko this is right it's just
the most boring and miserable type of
gambling i've ever experienced in my
life like at least when i lose in like
blackjack or something i'm like oh that
was oh
no no no condoning blackjack but like
just shooting a ball and just watching
it go in and then just like holding it
yeah for ten minutes you also don't know
what the [ __ ] happening halfway yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like i think i think
i'm winning i don't know it's like i'm
pretty sure like ninety percent of it is
rng and it's just like gameplay is just
do it do i hold this do i hold this
pachinko at a 90 degree angle or a 91
degree rng gone if you ask the people
it's not rng yeah but also they they
straps but also they like scout out
machines to see which ones have paid out
so people are like people will get there
like like
right before it opens and wait yeah like
wait for like hours just so they can get
the one machine that's going to pay out
yeah like i think it's cool to do is
like a one-time experience but then i
can't imagine how people spend hours
there it's depressing it stinks of smoke
it's it's [ __ ] it's so loud you can't it
can't do anything yeah [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
yeah rather get a hobby honestly yeah